- Hello everyone and welcome to
- [Crowd] Guess That Celebrity Product!
- Today's contestants are Kelsey,
Dalton,
and Shila.
Do you guys think that
you're pretty knowledgeable
in celebrity products and stuff?
- Sure.
- Whoa, that doesn't
sounds very convincing.
(laughter)
- I know Kylie has lipped kids.
- And I watch TMZ and
E! News all the time,
so I'm pretty confident.
- Is there a prize?
- There's the pride that
you know all the answers.
- That's okay, we were
planning on going out
for tequila shots afterwards.
- Cool, we'll handle it.
- Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- Alright ready, so bring
the first product over!
- [Dalton] Wait are we going?
It's a puppy!
- It is a puppy.
What the fuck is this, a puppy pillow?
A pillow puppy.
- It's a dog toy.
- Sarah McLachlan.
- Created by: one, Ellen DeGeneres.
Two, Jimmy Fallon.
Or three, Martha Stewart.
- Jimmy Fallon.
(buzz)
- Martha Stewart.
- [Host] Incorrect.
- What was the other one?
Wait, wait, wait, no, no.
Ellen DeGeneres.
(ding)
- [Host] That is correct.
(cheering)
Are you guys ready for the second product?
- I guess.
- [Host] Okay, bring it in.
- [Shila] Oh, I know this one.
- [Kelsey] Wow.
- I feel so cool like this.
- Do I look dumb?
- [Shila] You look dope.
- You guys probably know the answer,
but is it A. Katy Perry, B. Ariana Grande,
or three Meghan Trainor?
- It's Ariana Grande.
- [Host] That's correct.
So are you guys ready for the next one?
Alright, bring it in.
- [Contestants] Oh!
- Orange Nipple Balm?
- Organic, that says organic.
- A. Gwyneth Paltrow, B. Jessica Alba,
or C. Halle Berry?
(clacking)
- That was me, one
hundred thousand percent.
- What's your answer?
- Jessica Alba.
(ding)
- That is correct.
- Oh, it's the Honest Company,
it's her company.
Also, why does it have to be nipple balm?
- [Shila] I think you can use it for both.
- Can I keep that?
- [Host] Yeah.
- It's like Vaseline, like
what's the difference?
- Alrighty, next product.
A. Michael Strahan, B. Ryan Seacrest,
or C. David Beckham?
- Can we get hints?
Oh, she got it.
- [Host] She did the noise,
that's part of the game.
- Actually, no.
- [Host] Shila.
- David? David.
(buzz)
- Wrong.
(clacking)
- Can I ask a hint?
- [Kelsey] No.
- I didn't get a hint.
- You don't get to make
up the rules to this game.
- What did you say?
- Now I'm not saying.
- [Host] Come on, Dalton, you
had your say just give it.
- Michael Strahan.
- Nope, it's Ryan Seacrest.
I'm so good!
- I second guessed myself.
- Bring the last product over.
- [Kelsey] The fuck?
It's a perfume.
But let's see, what does it smell like?
Okay, here comes a community spray.
- Smells like a man.
- [Host] Oh, can I smell?
- Of course you can, you're the host.
- Is this perfume from A. Beyonce,
B. Jennifer Lopez, or C. Rihanna?
(clacking)
- [Host] That was Kelsey.
- Rihanna.
(ding)
- She's the winner!
(cheering)
- Gimme this, I'm keeping this too.
You can't have this.
- But I want a clapper.
- I'm the winner, I get it all.
- [Host] Oh my God, Kelsey
you killed it today.
- I know.
- Dalton, how do you
feel about not winning?
- Not good. I'm sad.
- It's okay, do you want this shirt?
I'm not gonna wear it.
- [Dalton] No, it's not my size.
I'm too fat.
- Shila, you got
headphones so you're fine.
- I feel like the real winner here.
I get Ariana headphones.
- What can I keep though?
I'm the host.
- You can have pride.
- Is there a prize?
- (slowly) The pride, the
pride, the pride that you know
all the answers.
- Alright guys, well that is it.
Congratulations to Kelsey.
(cheers)
- I win. I'm the winner.
- We'll see you next time on...
- Guess that Celebrity Product!
Wow, guys.
- We were actually serious that time.
- See you next time on...
- Guess that Celebrity Product!
- We out.
(game show music)
(whooshing)
(squeaks)